نعم دائما ما تكون ساعات الصباح ملئه
باحداث القصف الاسرائيلي خاصه ان القصف
الاسرائيلي متواصل منذ ساعات امس حتى هذه
اللحظه على مختلف المناطق سواء الغربيه او
الشماليه او الشرقيه او الجنوبيه هذه
المناطق كلها تعرضت للقصف لكن صباح هذا
اليوم قواه الاحتلال قصفت سياره مدنيه
تحتوي على ثلاث اشخاص جميعهم ارتقوا شهداء
بالاضافه الى قصف بيت في منطقه الصبره
يتبع لعائله رحيم واستشهدت سيده وبقيت تحت
الانقاظ بسبب الدمار الكبير الذي لحق
بالمنزل وتم اجلاء الاصابات المتواجده في
داخل المنزل اما عن المنطقه الجنوبيه
الغربيه التي هي تشهد محورا تواجد هذا
المحور الذي يشهد تواجد لقوات الاحتلال لا
صحت للاخبار المتداول على ان قوات
الاحتلال انسحبت من محيط دوار انصار او
ابو مازن قوات الاحتلال تتواجد بكثافه في
تلك المنطقه ووصل صباح اليوم عددا من
الشهداء داخل مجمع الشفاء الطبي بالاضافه
الى ما يقارب 13 اصابه من تلك المنطقه
بالقناصه الاسرائيليه ودبابات قوات
الاحتلال بالاضافه الى القصف المدفعي
المتواصل على هذه المنطقه لا زالت قوات
الاحتلال تمارس انشطتها العسكريه في
المنطقه الجنوبيه الغربيه على الرغم من
تعرضها لضربات من المقاومه وقصف من
القذائف الهاون المتواصل على هذه المنطقه
ب لازالت حتى هذه اللحظه ايضا المواجهات
ضاريه في ذاك المحور بالانتقال الى المحور
الشرقي ال الشمالي هذا المحور الذي هو مطل
على جبل الريس من من حي التفاح والدرج
بالاضافه الى منطقه شرق جباليا هذه
المنطقه ايضا تتواجد بها قوات الاحتلال
حتى هذه اللحظات وتحاول التقدم منذ ثلاثه
ايام او اربعه ايام بالتحديد حتى هذه
اللحظات لم تستطيع التقدم الى المناطق
الغربيه يبدو ان قوات الاحتلال تحاول
الاستمرار انشطتها العسكريه في مختلف
المناطق الشماليه لكن بطريقه محدوده جدا
تقدم محدود واستهداف لجميع المواطنين
الذين يتواجدون في اماكن التقدم حتى هذه
اللحظه الاوضاع متوتره في المناطق
الشماليه بشكل مستمر وقوات الاحتلال
تتواجد بكثافه على مختلف المحاور وتحاول
التموضع في تلك المحاور علما ان قوات
الاحتلال فجرت مربعات سكنيه في منطقه
المقوسي وايضا ايضا في المناطق الجنوبيه
الغربيه هذه المناطق التي شهدت انفجارات
عنيفه مساء امس وحتى هذه اللحظات الاحتلال
قوات الاحتلال تتواجد في تلك المنطقه شكرا
لك اسماعيل الغول مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا
من محيط مستشفى الشفاء في غزه